well as nevada tries to transition from  a record number of people on  unemployment we're now learning just how  much fraud actually  clogged up the system governor sisilak  says money to renovate our outdated  unemployment software from the  legislature will certainly help but  he told 8 news now that fraudulent  claims were a major problem all over the  country but especially here in nevada  dieter is a major problem i think anyone  can deny that  but you're finding out across the  country that the estimates are 50  percent of the cases  that were applied for adidas benefits  were fraudulent  i mean hundreds of millions of dollars  were applied for  and money got paid out on fraudulent  claims and we need to do more in concert  with the attorney general  department of justice to prosecute those  people nevada is using federal funds to  help modernize our unemployment system